yep that's ariana grande's wig flying
off her head in a clip from jimmy
fallon's music trivia game show that's
my jam how is that a thing oh my god
yeah let's see that again i think we
need to see an instant replay on that
one
it's ruining my whole vibe ariana and
her fellow voice coaches blake shelton
john legend and kelly clarkson competed
against each other as contestants on the
new nbc game show during a segment
called airguitar where teams of two go
head to head answering music trivia
questions the winners score points and
the losing team gets a big blow of air
to the face it's good for the nervous
system ari played it cool and kept the
game moving but she and teammate blake
couldn't quite seem to get any wins i'm
begging you me to just take a shot yeah
i'm begging you to know this i want to
say uh i can't feel like john and kelly
on the other hand knew their trivia you
may know him as dwayne michael carter jr
lil wayne or wheezy but what was his
original rap name i'm leaving shrimp
daddy he's from new orleans and he's
small
i love
they even got a question about a furry
friend who belongs to one of the coaches
what is the name of ariana grande's pet
pig
piggy smalls yes unfortunately for ari
they have the right answer in the bag
and this one literally blew her away
again
the silver lining the pop star's got a
true family and her voice co-stars this
is a good test of our friendship that
means i listen when you tell stories
about your pets oh i love you and i know
yeah your pet's name is piggy that was
in our group chat the musicians also
went head to head and a variety of other
games in the show including a bit where
they sing classics from fellow pop divas
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and taking it a step further kelly and
ariana saying each other's hits during a
game called slay it don't spray it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
season 21 of the voice introduced the
god as a woman singer to the group and
just ahead of the season premiere the
coaches revealed to e.t how intimidated
they felt about a powerhouse like ari
joining the fam of course she's a threat
yeah of course she's a threat she is
hugely talented hugely successful
there's no disadvantage when you're
ariana grande
i was a huge fan of the voice i have
watched many seasons and i love watching
the show it always has the best energy
and it's very amazing and i feel so
grateful to be here after the first live
episodes aired john dished on how the
show has impacted ari and you really
feel the emotion of it and then of
course
particularly for ariana being a new
coach and falling in love with her
artist and then finding out she has to
send one home every time it's like it's
pretty tough and you can see how
emotional that is for her speaking of
emotions they were running high all
season culminating with a big season 21
win from girl named tom a band on team
kelly the winner of the voice is
girl named tom
et spoke with the miss independent
singer after the big win and offered her
best advice it's so important to
surround yourself with such a good team
of good people that you trust and you
want to work with and because that's it
it's like you have the talent you have
the package you write you do all these
things like it's about finding people to
be on your team that believe in you to
get you there and that's a huge thing
that i learned the hard way and had to
like find out cheers to more wins and
hopefully for re less moments like this
[Music]
you